breaking news Bitcoin has just hit this  year's all-time low at 16 800 so here's  where I think it's going to go next we  have key support at around seventeen  thousand dollars so if we end up  breaking this support at around sixty  thousand eight hundred to seventy  thousand dollars it's very likely we  could see a pullback as low as twelve  thousand to fourteen thousand dollars  this would be an eighty percent sell-off  from its all-time high of sixty nine  thousand dollars which would also mirror  the previous Market but it's not all bad  news one year ago when Bitcoin was at  its all-time high people would be  praying for cheaper prices to get in at  anything under twenty thousand dollars  to me is a steal so I'll be buying more  Bitcoin as we make lower lows